WE WON'T GO.
A COUNTRY AFRAID TO TOUCH OTHER
PEOPLE IS A COUNTRY WE DON'T
WANT TO LIVE IN.
McDONALD IS THE AUTHOR OF
DIVERSITY OF DELUSION AND JOINS
US, HEATHER THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON.
IN THE PAST 24 HOURS RETHINKING
THIS QUESTION WE JUMPED HEADLONG
IN THE MOCKING OF JOE BIDEN
WHICH IS FINE, I THINK BUT
NANCY PELOSI SAID WHAT WE JUST
PLAYED HER SAYING WHICH IS, WE
REALLY OUGHT TO APPROACH OTHER
PEOPLE IF WE ALL HAVE COLDS AND
ARM LINKS RELATIONSHIP WITH
PEOPLE WE ARE NOT RELATED TO.
WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY IS SHE
DESCRIBING?
>> Heather: AND IN HUMAN ONE,
TUCKER NO FORGIVENESS, NO
ACCEPTANCE OF DIFFERENCES OF
BEHAVIOR.
WE ARE TO BE FOR DIVERSITY,
RIGHT?
HOW ABOUT DIVERSITY OF AN OLDER
GENERATION THAT HAS A DIFFERENT
STYLE OF ENGAGEMENT AND HAS NOT
BEEN TERRORIZED INTO FRIGID,
SELF-CRITICISM BY THE FEMINIST
THAT CANNOT UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT HUMAN BEINGS
COMMIT DIFFERENT WAYS OF
RELATING TO PEOPLE.
THIS IS GOING TO AND NORMAL
HUMAN AND INTERCOURSE AS WE KNOW
IF IT ALLOWED TO GET AWAY WITH
THIS.
THE FEMALES HAVE SAID THERE IS
NOTHING ABOUT IT.
OKAY THE CONVERSATION SHOULD AND
THEY ARE.
BUT NEW STANDARD NOW, THE
FEMINISTS ARE SETTING IS THEY
DETERMINE BY THEIR SUBJECTIVE
EXPERIENCE IN CHARACTER OF
EXPERIENCES.
THERE IS NO REASONABLE PERSON
STANDARD OR THE DISPUTE AS BIDEN
SAID MY HAD NO INTENTION TO
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
I WAS NOT INTENDING ANYTHING.
NONE OF THAT MATTERS NOW.
IF A FEMINISTS FEELS OFFENDED
THE INTERACTION IS OBJECTIVELY
OFFENSIVE AND THAT IS A RECIPE
FOR CHAOS AND ILL -- ALIENATION.
>> Tucker: THINK YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND INCREASINGLY SO I THINK A
LOT OF US I WILL SPEAK FOR
MYSELF, SOMETHING AMUSING ABOUT
WATCHING THE LEFT EAT ITSELF
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO ADHERE TO
THEIR OWN LITTLE CRYSTAL.
THEY ARE LIVING IN THE PC.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO JOE BIDEN
IS WITH A PLAN FOR THE REST OF
US.
>> Heather: AND WHAT HE PLANS
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT IS HARD NOT TO TAKE A GLEE IN
THIS BECAUSE IT IS CERTAINLY
TURNAROUND IS FAIR PLAY.
THIS IS A MAN WHO UNLEASHED THE
WAR ON DUE PROCESS AND CAMPUS
TRIBUNAL AND UNLEASHED FEMINIST
TROPE ABOUT PHANTOM CULTURE FOR
THE LAST THREE DECADES.
AND SO IT IS PURELY JUST,
NEVERTHELESS, I URGE YOU, TUCKER
TO STEP UP, UP PURE POLITICAL
VENDETTA AND SAY, WHAT IS AT
STAKE IS THE LIVABILITY OF HUMAN
SOCIETY.
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
ALL PEOPLE, PEOPLE HAVE TO BE A
LITTLE FLEXIBLE BUT THE
FEMINISTS IS BRITTLE.
IT IS INTOLERANT, UNFORGIVING,
AND IT IS UTTERLY NARCISSISTIC.
THESE FEMALES ARE SAGGING, THEY
ARE WORLDVIEW, THEIR SUBJECTIVE
EXPERIENCE SHOULD BE NOW THE NEW
NORM FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT IT
IS OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE WHAT
THEY ARE -- THEIR INTERPRETATION
IS.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO NONLIBERALS?
THE TEMPTATION WILL BE TO ENGAGE
IN EXACTLY THE BEHAVIOR THAT YOU
CRITICIZE AND OTHERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE
DESTROYING POLITICIANS,
BERNIE SANDERS APPARENTLY MAY BE
LEAKED THIS AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
SO CONSERVATIVES CAN BECOME
GRIEVED AND USE THE SAME STYLE
BUT THAT IS A TRAP I THINK.
>> Heather: ABSOLUTELY YOU
HAVE TO REALIZE THE PRINCIPLE
MATTERS.
AND THE PRESIDENT YOU ARE
SETTING WILL BE USED AGAINST
YOU.
THERE IS ALWAYS CHANGE OF POWER.
AND THE IDEA FOR THAT EXPERIENCE
IS TO LIVE BY SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT SHEER PARTISAN VENGEANCE.
ANTISEPTIC PRINCIPLES THAT YOU
ARE HAPPY TO LIVE WITH FOR
YOURSELF AND OTHER PEOPLE.
AND SO IN THIS CASE AS TEMPTING
AS BIDEN IS FOR A TARGET AND
CERTAINLY THE STRONGEST
CONTENDER AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
BUT HIS OWN HISTORY OF STOKING
THE FEMINIST FURY AGAIN WE
SHOULD NOT GO DOWN THAT PATH.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU, THERE WILL
BE A WHOLE LINE OF REPUBLICAN
POLITICIANS WHO DESERVE TO
SUCCEED WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE
PHOTOS TAKEN OF THEM WHEN THEY
GOT AN ARM AROUND SOMEBODY.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE A
PHYSICAL HUMAN BEING.
I WILL TELL YOU THE OTHER THING
THAT WE CAN SEE WHERE THIS IS
TAKING US, ANTIOCH COLLEGE
WIDELY MOCKED 1994 POLICY FOR
DRUNKEN CAMPUS HOOK UPS.
SAID EVERY LAST GROPE HAS TO BE
EXPLICITLY AGREED TO.
EVERYBODY SAID THIS WAS CRAZY.
TWO DECADES LATER EVERY COLLEGE
HAS THAT.
AND NOW, IMPLYING FROM A
PLATONIC TOUCH, NOW A DAUGHTER
OBJECTS TO HER MOTHER HUGGING
HER BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T GET
CONSENT.
THIS IS WHERE THIS WILL TAKE US,
TUCKER.